i like watching hollywood burn you know
watching
hollywood's new shows come out and they
suck and you know
me and my friends are making stuff that
everyone likes and is resonating with
them and i
i think i like the competition element
of that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating
people i'm delighted to say our
brilliant guest today is the comedian
ryan long ryan welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me guys oh listen
man it's great to have you on a lot of
our audience have been
clamoring for us to talk to you because
you've been putting out some great stuff
uh during the last year the pandemic etc
before we dive into all of that talk
about comedy and more
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life that
lead you here
cool i was uh so when i was
pretty young i was in like a pretty
successful band in canada and then i
kind of
was doing all these dvds jackass kind of
style stuff and tom green was huge for
me and then i took
uh i ended up doing a tv show in canada
kind of based on that stuff when i was
doing all these dvds with the band and
stuff
um in that time i started doing comedy
so that would have been like 11 or 12
years ago i started doing stand-up
and i was doing tv shows and sketch
comedy and i did a series at the cbc i
built up the
video department for the thing a website
called the hard times
then i moved to america uh about a year
and a half ago kind of right before the
pandemic and started doing my own stuff
here and then
now i'm just kind of doing my own
youtube channel and touring and stuff as
a comic
and you're crushing it and one of the
things i found really interesting is
a lot of your stuff at the moment is
people would say it's political you talk
about
woke culture some of the flaws were that
way of thinking
uh you've talked about the restrictions
around lockdowns and the pandemic
but actually you say you're someone
who's not political in the sense you
don't care who the president is etc is
that
broadly accurate yeah i think i mean
there's a lot of people that are
probably in a similar position in that
i talk about culture and that's what i
talk about and i think most importantly
i talk about people
and the psychology of people and you
know stuff like that
and politics has infiltrated
every single facet of the world right i
mean especially during the trump years
there wasn't anyone that wasn't talking
about all that stuff right so
it's impossible to separate the two so
it's not that i'm completely
um you know it's impossible
to ignore and i went through when i was
in university i went to school for
economics and i went through my
phase where i was you know you know very
and all that stuff and
and i had my perspective or whatever and
then it kind of it came back around
um now but i think a lot of times
there's there's there are some people
that really
are part of you know we want our side to
win and i think that i'm
usually talking about that stuff but
more importantly i'm talking about the
psychology of the people that are like
that
so even in my videos like when you talk
if you you mentioned that i mention i
talk about you know
cancer culture work stuff or whatever
let's say that's one of the things right
i'm generally talking about the type of
person that does that
you know and and the psychology behind
them and what they do and i think that's
kind of
generally what i'm poking fun of one of
the things that just to
kind of elaborate on that or whatever
but one of the things i think i was
thinking about a lot this week
is and this is why
it's gotten like this is because there's
probably
i don't know if you saw this but glenn
danzig who's like the the misfits guy
he's like a big punk guy
he kind of came out and he said that you
know his songs wouldn't be able to be
made but right now where punk wouldn't
have happened because of you know woke
[ __ ] is what he said
and obviously the the punk community
flipped out and everyone you know he's
just old you don't get it whatever it is
right
and it's kind of and by the way the
lyrics of it were
you know i'm gonna rape your mom and
stuff like that so it was i don't even
know
why it would be you know they don't like
the way you said that but it's pretty
obvious that yes
for sure that couldn't have happened
right now like none of them would have
been for it
but all those a lot of those people like
that band and i think that
once you control people's identity you
kind of control everything about them so
let's say i go i'm a punk or i'm a this
and then all
once people think that then all you have
to say is well guess what
people who are that think this and i
think that's kind of
you know i've even said you know like
guys like brad weinstein and stuff like
that
how they're always having that
conversation you know i'm actually a
liberal but
you know the word liberal has changed a
lot and these words always change right
so i think that's why i never really
attach myself to i'm this or i'm that
because they change every two years
and you know realistically who you are
is you know gonna change at a slow pace
but things can change rapidly and if the
words that define you
or how you see yourself the most
important thing then you're just
beholden to other people's definitions
of who you are
and i think that's where a lot of people
are at right now it's a very interesting
point you make
ryan now let's be honest in the comedy
industry
most people would describe themselves as
liberal
you know in inverted commas as it were
do you think that's where the industry
is now and how do you see yourself
in the industry well so even to go back
to my original point you said most
people and entertainment comedy would
ever describe themselves as liberal like
so is that because most people that are
liberal get into entertainment or was it
because once you get into entertainment
that's a requirement is that your this
they go well if you're if you're an
artist you're obviously this
so people go okay because they didn't
want to lose the identity that they're
an artist
so if you said hey i want to be in a
punk band and you go well all punks
think this you go okay well i'm that now
you know so
that became like a secondary term that
got attached to people that want the
first you know want to be able to attach
the first identity to themselves
do you think it's become more intolerant
though because before
like well i started comedy disclosure in
2009
and it was a very very different
landscape back then back then it was
you know more to do everybody wanted to
be sort of like a shock jock
comedian yeah the agiera yeah yeah
say the most outrageous thing not your
grandmother's comedy
let me tell you i'm sorry exactly
whereas now it seems we've flipped over
completely on the in the other side
yeah i think that there's probably a
good um
it's probably worth making the
definition between mainstream comedy and
comedy so
i mean yeah if you're talking about like
hollywood and movies and tv shows
that are made by the you know corporate
comedy industry
yeah they've got a very specific
perspective but then there's also a
counter culture that you know is kind of
against that which you know you guys
would be part of you have an
audience i'm doing very well so there's
always a counter culture and a lot of
times things were originally a counter
culture and you can even see
what we're talking about okay so perfect
example
that was sort of like a hipster
counterculture at one point being
you know uh against america it was
almost like a mix between libertarian
and you know kind of edgy
liberals right where we're against the
government and we're
you know against racism and whatever
like you know all that kind of stuff
right
and then now you saw you still kind of
see this counterculture and you probably
say the biggest person in that field
would be like joe rogan you know i would
say that's the
the biggest person in that whole field
and he's made a lot of careers or
whatever
so if you now look at that you'll see
fox news and places like that
kind of attaching themselves to that
counterculture right so and then
you know they're trying to say it's a
right left thing but it's not it's
always a kind of freedom
versus authoritarian thing right and
you'll see other people the same way
that
they attach them like the whatever
mainstream corporate america attached
themselves to that and you see
the same reason you see that you know
axe body sprays got ads about racism or
whatever it is right when
you know what were they they were
literally the you know company three
years ago that was like you know have
sex
at a fret you know that was their motto
basically right so it all
it changes and you'll see that other
people that
sort of take what movements are and it
happen and then
uh chew them up and spit them out and it
happened it happens most purely in music
but
in comedy it probably happens more
pronounced because
in comedy the the your opinions are
the product a lot of times right so what
your opinions are are the products so
once they kind of co-opt that then they
then they own everything and all they
have to be is like what were all those
kids saying that
it's been going popular oh yeah we're
that now
well i i really think it's funny to
watch because
um you know sometimes you'll say that uh
let's say
i assume you guys are always a you know
a lot against the people that are
clamping down on freedoms especially in
speech and all that stuff and you know
as am i
and so you i i did like a
fox thing right and these people they're
very
like you can't say anything anymore
right they're kind of saying you know
what
the chewed up and spit out version of
what probably people like you are saying
they go
you know you're not allowed to say
anything anymore i go first of all i'm
not allowed to swear on this very
interview
and i go go watch a bill o'reilly clip
from six years ago it's him
interviewing you know the insane clown
posse being like but aren't you hurt
words hurtful like this should not be
you know exact same thing
it's just repackaged because you know
they have less
power in in in censorship probably right
now
i think you're you're so right about
that i think there is a lot of sort of
jumping on bandwagons from from both
sides and that's what i always found
quite frustrating i don't know if people
tried to do this to you
but i found the moment you start
speaking out and going actually maybe it
is important that people should be saved
what be able to say what they think
or make the jokes that they want
suddenly everyone's like your right wing
and i'm like
whoa yeah like how did that happen
when did being for freedom become a
right-wing thing do you do people
well it became when they polarized
everything when they decided that you
know if you're a liberal here are the 12
things you think and if you're a
conservative here are the 12 things you
think
and most people aren't like that like
everyone has their group of friends and
maybe this guy's a little this on this
issue and everyone sort of talks about
things so the idea that
if you if you're part of this identity
here's the 12 things you think and they
do it with race they do with gender they
do it with jobs
you know if you're you know the old you
know even with people who are against
the cops
there's this code among cops of like you
don't say this to this person and that's
kind of how they operate but more
importantly it kind of becomes
uh so when you're doing it the other way
like what you're talking about when
they're trying to shut it down
that's that idea that let's make a thing
that you're not you don't that it's not
acceptable to be and then once we've got
on board with that
let's put everyone in that group so but
they don't update like
you know it's the thing they go
everyone's conservative that's what
they're saying anyone i disagree with is
conservative and they kind of know that
in their little faction of the world
they don't have to tell you why they're
wrong all they have to tell you is this
and then they already know it's wrong so
it's sort of like a
a cheap way to argue about people with
people is you just tell them they're
this group that you don't like you know
what i mean
if imagine you were talking about sports
in a bar and i don't know
we probably know different teams cause
i'm you know i'm from canada and
i live in america and you guys are from
but the you know if you were
team a and you're arguing about the
players and you go dude he's a friggin
leafs fan he he's not gonna don't care
what he says
that's all you would have to say is he's
at least he's a leafs fan or a
manchester fan
and then his opinion's no longer valid
right and then he might be like no i'm
not i
it doesn't matter they just so they put
you in that box and then the other way
is when they're doing it on your side
and i think jon stewart actually was
set a pretty good version of this back
in the day that i always kind of
think probably summed it up best he goes
people are always going to weaponize you
so you know it's you'll see the same
people get weaponized both ways like a
bill maher type
you'll see every now and then liberals
being like look this is you know
this is ah in your face and then you'll
see the conservatives being like ah like
and he kind of switches back and forth
but everyone likes to
use him and i think for a while
comedians specifically
were sort of looked at as an impartial
source
so so it can be sort of like if you're
trying to make some political point and
then you can be
look at this comedian even gets it and
they're they know that you're wrong
whereas i think that's
now comedians are probably just as
divided as anywhere else and i think
that has lost its charm a little bit
and do you think we're we're at quite a
perilous point for comedy ryan
where you see comedians getting
cancelled people making jokes
people having to apologize for things
that they said three years ago etc etc
so i'm i i think that's probably a
example of something that i think a lot
of people
want me to think that but i don't like i
don't feel like i'm a victim in this
scenario
i think that listen i was in canada and
it's a very small place and it didn't
really have enough room for a counter
culture i saw a really cool one going on
here that i
was a part with aligned with what i
thought and i thought that it was the
stuff i wanted to make i was at
places like cbc which you have the bbc
and i wanted to make this kind of stuff
and they wouldn't let you know it was i
squeaked some through i made like a
libertarian sketch with government money
which i thought was kind of funny
um but when i came here i think comedy's
great and i've been able to create my
own platform and all these people and i
think that there's
because there's so many people probably
like you or me
that maybe 10 years ago you would have
entered the industry system and
you probably would have been more
handcuffed than you are now so
i think a better way to describe it is
that hollywood's failing
and they're missing this whole thing and
they're you know they they're trying to
they have this big distribution but they
think they can pick people but they
can't
they go you know oh this guy's the hot
comedian or a woman's a hot comedian and
anyone
has a eyes and a brain is like what are
you talking about
this is a real thing it's like you know
it's like if you were
running a basketball team and you go
this guy is going to be the star and
then you go
i mean we can see that they scored no
points
joining me i mean you're things
connecting with people because it's
probably good
do you know what i mean well i agree
with you ryan but see this is where i
i i am totally on your side i found
myself on countless tv shows going
no no you can still do jokes like it's
possible right
the the mob of people in the comedy club
aren't jumping on stage and dragging you
out
and beating you with their pink hair or
whatever i'm not
definitely not saying that right no i
mean it has happened to you
no but it hasn't this is the thing right
so on the one hand
but on the other hand i also think about
this like you are successful you've got
a platform
we've had some success with this i mean
it has cost us largely our mainstream
comedy career in this country but who
gives a [ __ ] right because
as you say it's mostly not very good
anyway but
a newer comedian coming through now
who's trying to make the
the bones in the clubs who's trying to
go through
you talk about canada in the uk it's
also quite a small market
everyone knows each other and if you
become known as the comedian the quote
says the wrong thing or votes the wrong
way or has the wrong opinions
that does tend to be quite restrictive
and that's where
i've always sort of tried to to draw a
line between yeah if you're ricky
gervais
or whoever you can do any joke you want
because you've got your own audience
you've got your own platform
for a younger newer comic coming through
i think the climber is very restrictive
would you would you agree with me okay
so i
i i've said a version of what you just
said as well and i know what you're
saying
it's for example you'll see some of
these really big comedians kind of say
you can say anything and you'll
well you can because you're in a legacy
position and
and they're they're sort of somewhat
immune to that but
the true there's all there's pros and
cons to both of this is sort of more
what i'm saying because i'm not negating
the fact
that you know it's very not it's very
stressful having all these people come
after you
you know it's uh it's very difficult
you're right uh
you're constantly at battle with um how
your
reputation is perceived with what you
actually say and then how people want to
say that you are and you're like i'm not
that so you're con so
i think that for one yeah comedy's
really hard
and all and it always has been so this
idea that
if you go back to the what you said
about this person that's two years in
and they go
well they can't say anything and you go
the truth is my advice to those people
is you're probably not ready to talk
about these topics anyway so it is very
clumsy and
there is places you can do there's
always going to be a little scene of
edgy boys or whatever right
but yeah it is difficult and it's it's
it's a different ecosystem to navigate
and i mean if you go back to lenny bruce
he was going to jail for this stuff and
i know that
you know you have people and and now um
in the uk that have
you know actually been a jail and
there's other you know people that have
been fined like mike ward in canada
who's been fined and
there is similarities and this is a up
and down thing and especially in the
trump years it became ex
exceedingly the consequences are high
and the rewards can also be high i mean
that's why jordan peterson's the biggest
intellectual figure of
probably our generation right um and
then
and the rewards on that path also
involve freedom which i don't think
there was the
the biggest version of that seven years
ago so it always depends who you are so
i think a lot of people who value safety
and to go back to that freedom safety
conversation like
a lot of people who value safety you're
right this
comedy sucks way more than it would
before but if you're someone who kind of
considers himself like a
you know let's say a rebel or
counterculture or a troublemaker
i think wherever you went you'd probably
find yourself kind of causing trouble
and
so you might maybe it's more attractive
to you
i don't know so it's just it changed and
it's different and probably whether it's
better or worse depends on who you are
i mean what i i see both of it because
to be honest i am a little bit
uh polite i don't know maybe i'm not
polite to the right word but like
you're canadian roy i'm canadian but i
really do see it in a way that i've
inserted myself into all these fights
and i'm constantly a battle and i'm you
know i'm i'm releasing a video
every monday sometimes every wednesday
too that
is causing it like a shitstorm you know
what i mean
and you know a part of me um
i think there's the americans that their
their culture is way more
confrontational like someone bumps into
you you go
what are you doing what are you looking
at like that kind of thing right well
i'm a little more oh so
so i am sort of you know navigating how
to
uh make my personality fit with the
my propensity to you know poke the bear
and that's all
difficult but at the same time i'm you
know going out on weekends and selling
out shows and you said that
you pointed out something that for the
newer comedian you know
i wasn't when i moved to america i was i
didn't have this i was part of the
legacy system so i was doing my cbc
shows
so my i don't know whatever you want
whatever i have right now
happened during this like i got popular
in america in the last year do you know
what i mean
so that and it was because of this stuff
you know because i was
standing up to this and so yeah there is
only certain people that have the
ability to do that and it takes a
certain type of character and a certain
type of
uh resilience and i think a lot of times
it does help to have been doing this for
a long time
because you're really you understand
your beliefs and you can defend them
from first principles and you're
confident what you think and i
know how i make videos because you have
everyone yelling at you you start to be
like
am i wrong do i suck you know so i think
it it helps to
really spend the time to get great at
this and it helps to
really spend the time to like understand
what you think and that's
what i'm trying to like continue to do
but i think that probably the best
answer is that there's pros and cons and
that depends on who you are where you
are in your career
and what your what your like personality
type is
hey francis do you like martians well i
work with one don't i
would you like an immersive experience
with the marshall are you gonna get me
drunk on the vodka
me and my stinks like last time you wish
no there's this great new immersive
experience in london
based on jeff wayne's the war of the
world i've heard about this the audience
reviews have been incredible
it was rated one of the top 20 things to
do in london
at night and 98 of guests recommend it
yes the experience features a cast of 17
characters
12 live actors plus a mix of holograms
projections
and vr of west end stars you'll feel all
your senses fired as you crawl slide and
weave your way through
22 000 feet of immersive action
including 24 extraordinary scenes
and having to escape 300 foot marsha
machines
and the evacuation of london not the
first time london has been evacuated
this year
this award-winning experience is only in
london for a limited time from the 22nd
of may over a thousand performances are
already fully booked
and june is selling out fast it's fully
compliant with kovid regulations and
they're offering
10 pound off of two or more tickets with
the promo code trigger 10
that's 10 pound off two or more tickets
with the promo code
trigger 10. all you need to do to take
advantage of this
fantastic offer is go to thewar
of the worlds immersive.com that's the
war
of the worlds immersive.com and
experience a world where we're being
invaded by martians which is still
better than being locked down
follow the link in the description and
we'll see you there guys
and ryan you you said that you know
you're on cbc you had this mainstream
career
why did you step out in that case and do
what you're doing
would did you have a road to damascus
moment or was it a gradual thing
well you know you know some of my
friends in canada their comics you said
and obviously they all moved there from
it's it's almost like not an option i'm
sure you
because uk is sort of the other the
second place probably after america in
terms of you know whatever cultural
significance in the
english world or whatever right so i
mean i'm sure you guys know people from
australia
and new zealand whatever it is that
moved to uk it's like it's almost just
what you do
so i there was and then part of it was
because i was doing such aggressive
stuff and because of what i was doing
there was just no room for that in cbc
and i was
in places like that and i was just
fighting this uphill battle and i knew
that
i knew that there was something that i
wanted to be a part of in america for a
long time it just
i thought i was ready and it took me two
years to get my green card and
immigration stuff and all that kind of
stuff like that's why they all come to
uk because you can
immigrate to uk without going through
the whole process and immigrating
we have we need to build a wall yeah i
know
a snow wall a snowball they call that
no you have to there was but i like it
better i mean i'm a guy that likes
freedom you know i'm sure there's people
in canada that have their comfortable
you know essentially government
subsidized comedy jobs and they like
that
i didn't want that i wanted to you know
kind of be in these more uncharted
waters and i
liked the renaissance against like i
like watching hollywood burn
you know watching hollywood's new shows
come out and they
suck and you know me and my friends are
making stuff that everyone
likes and is resonating with them and i
i think i like the
competition element of that and i've so
i think it's cool and i always
i always knew that i would move here it
was just a matter of when is the right
time and i picked the perfect time right
before the country shuts down
indefinitely
yeah and it's interesting to me you
talking about it because i we feel very
similar about
our careers like we took some risks and
we we
we're reaping the rewards right and it's
kind of the same with you
but but the traditional big risk it is a
big risk right
you potentially ruin your life like you
know what i mean
right especially if you know they take
the wrong 14 second sound bite i mean
like i said i mean you know some people
come out of it some people don't i mean
i know people in canada
that were that have had things happen to
them that they didn't do
like i know for a fact they didn't do
the person eventually admitted they
didn't do it
and it they got so ostracized they got
kicked out of their
agency they got kicked out of their uh
uh
uh manager and the comedy clubs like
stop booking them they got fired from
the comedy agency which is the main one
that runs all the clubs
they essentially like walked into the
ocean and just never came back
like everyone's like are they gonna
commit suicide like it was very sad and
you feel bad for those people
but that being said if that was someone
else they might have been like
if you guys like that no you know and
someone they might have fought and
it just and maybe that would have ended
up different for them and they would
have developed a different type of
audience but
depends who you are and depends what
your preference is what this is what i
was going to say is
did you always feel this way because i
think it's very easy to feel this way
when you are being successful when you
have a show that's working when you're
putting out videos that getting hundreds
of thousands of views
did you feel was there no part of you
that you were like of the cbc going well
why can't i do counter cultural stuff in
the mainstream media
because 10 15 20 years ago there were
people who were doing that in the uk
for example right correct yeah was there
a part of you that's like why the [ __ ]
why why is this being restricted why do
i have to move to another country why
can't i do this
yeah i think i've probably like you guys
went through a bunch of different
versions of being mad and not mad yeah
yeah i think i did go through a lot of
those especially near the beginning
where you know you start to you go what
the why is everyone against me right now
you know what i mean
i'm doing a show it's the number one
thing on your network
and i'm being treated like i'm the worst
like you know i would have these
early on digital anyway but i was having
these all of those things but in terms
of
did i always feel like this i mean i was
the guy that was you know kicked out of
school and then kicked out of my
residence when i went to university and
spent most of my
high school years in the office and
police stations and
do you know what i mean and then i
formed a band and we were the ones that
were getting kicked off
i was just i've been a nuisance my
entire life
probably is but so if anything this is
probably the
most productive nuisance that i've been
when i i essentially
instead of you know wrecking my personal
life and being a problem in schools and
stuff
i think that i've found a way to channel
my
propensity to be a troublemaker into
probably something that's
kind of productive and actually makes
people feel good and a lot of people i
think i make them happier so
i think that that's uh probably a
positive
uh move forward in my life but it wasn't
a switch i think i was this person since
i was
four and we we're talking about your
comedy
why do you think is is it's resonated as
it has it gets
you know it's very very funny it gets
hundreds and
thousands of views why do you think
people latch on to it and share it and
enjoy it so much
i think that it's a combination of
things i liked uh
you know scott adams you know what you
guys know scott adams
he's cool right he always kind of talks
about this thing where
you know you don't have it's not about
being the best at things but if you're
the best of three things you're sort of
the
you know the inventing of a new category
and i and tim ferriss i mean i like
those guys like tim ferriss in that
whole world that kind of
was the first people that introduced me
to sort of a different way of uh
thinking of problem solving i think if
that makes sense but
with me i think that one
if so i'm i was a really good stand-up
comic
and then i was a really good musician
and i spent you know 20 years getting
good at making videos right
and one of the reasons i was really good
at making videos is because i was sort
of editing music
editing these two three-minute sketches
like their little music videos
and even the way that i kind of looked
at the voice versus the
what part of it's the drums and the way
that i kind of structure them all like
songs
so i kind of invented my own little way
to do it and then on top of that i think
that
the comic part where i i really spent 11
years honing
the ability to sort of like point out
one thing
you know when you're making fun of
something like what's the what's really
the thing that's wrong with this at its
core you know what i mean
um so i think that when i that
was the ability to kind of go viral was
i was really able to like isolate
what's the issue with with um you know
an ideology or a group of people or
or um you know a cultural phenomenon
what's lame about it or what's wrong
with it what's inconsistent about it
and i think so the mix of that versus
kind of inventing my own way to make
videos um
and then editing and those that like
kind of combination
and then on top of that sort of being
having uh views that aligned with sort
of
the cultural renaissance i think it was
the combination of all those things that
kind of made
my videos unique it was like
maybe there was people that understand
you know this cultural stuff a little
better than me
but not ones that are anywhere near as
good as i am at making videos
and maybe there's people that are good
at making videos that aren't as good at
really understanding
these cultural elements and the comedy
elements so i think maybe
the reason why my stuff kind of maybe is
connecting is
a combination of those three things and
at the
axis of all those graphs it might i
might be the best
for that little niche anyway yeah well
that makes sense and
you you talked a lot about how your
videos are causing a bit of a stir
or a [ __ ] storm depending on which one
it is uh
who is it that's coming after you or
having a go you are unhappy with the
videos that you're making
i mean literally every
everyone dude people i mean comics a lot
of comics is funny when they
they get mad at you you know what i mean
does that not piss you off because i'm
i that always frustrates me like
comedians having to go
other comedians do you find that
frustrating or is it like finally i've
made it i've done it now i'm really
doing good work
i think it'll be a third thing where i i
really try to be
honest about what people think and what
their motivations are
so i think that even when you're you're
doing comedy i think one of the reasons
why comedy was
getting weird in the mainstream is they
were like being dishonest they were
making
even say like you're making fun of trump
and just be like a stupid idiot you know
and it was kind of
that's not really what's happening so it
was caricatures as opposed to like
understanding what
so i usually try to like understand
people's motivations and i mean if i was
someone that had some legacy position
and then
these this group of people come around
that are doing something
i can't do and it's you know because i
i can't make that stuff while you know
uh basically being part of this club
so i can't make that and then it's doing
better i think the propensity would be
to be like well this shouldn't be
happening
because how would how else would you be
i don't know so i think that
a lot of people deal it differently i
mean there's a million people that
message me and they go
you know they love it right a million
million comics that
you'll see some comics kind of get mad
and then i'm like you're four of your
friends like messaged me
you know and they're and i know they're
lying i have people
that went online and they go ryan's
videos suck this and that and i go
my last message from them was when i was
doing the hard times video being like
this is brilliant
you know like i'm like i have a message
from you three years ago you saying that
i'm like a brilliant filmmaker
essentially
and then now because the topic's
something that you disagree with all of
a sudden
man that sucks in three years i went
from brilliant uh you can barely do it
so i i think that a lot of times if you
actually look deeper you kind of
it's like when a couple's fighting and
it's never about the issue there's
always kind of more to it
so i think maybe i don't know what do
you what do you guys think that
is going on with comics do you think
that they're actually so wrapped up that
they're in the cult or do you think that
there is a self-preservation mechanism
or a combination or how do you see it
i i see it as from and look a large part
of this stuff is
that you know you're projecting all the
rest of it i just think they're [ __ ]
oh no
[Laughter]
reduction
[Laughter]
they just got to the chase you mean like
they're bitter
i i think i think genuinely i think that
comedy especially in the uk it
encourages a group thing
it encourages a system or a mentality
whereby
you have to do certain things in order
to become successful
you get your you taught your five then
you get a 10 then you do you get your
comedy
yeah exactly and then you progress
through the clubs and then you do an
edinburgh show and
then you get divorced yeah yeah all the
rest of it and then
and part of that is having the right
opinions it's being left it's being
liberal it's being all the rest of it
and then you become weaponized yeah
you're just a weapon yeah and then all
of a sudden you see somebody
who doesn't do that or goes against the
grain and becomes successful
it makes you upset and angry because
they're doing it and they haven't
done it the way you've done it they
haven't done it in adverted commerce
the right way yeah they haven't followed
the methodology they're supposed to
follow give
give you an example that you might find
this interesting so my journey really on
the on this sort of thing started
in at the end of 2018. i was booked to
perform
at a charity night for a universe a
college uh
and they sent me a contract which said
that they had a
zero tolerance policy on about 23
different things like racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
and when i turned it down it just
randomly became a big news story
nice yeah you're like get out of here
with this yeah
but and see i thought i'm like i'm sort
of like standing up for the for the art
form i'm like protecting comedy and
comedians from these
uh lunatics who want to put rules on
everything and they did not see it like
that ah
no yeah they're working for the rule
makers
right well they're essentially the the
the laugh
arm of like a political party
and that's exactly it you know and it's
you know you can make if you want to do
politics you can make jokes absolutely
you can
but they have to be from this particular
viewpoint about
these topics yeah i mean yeah you're
color inside the lines
yeah to go back to what we're saying i
go okay
you know when you were probably a kid
like you probably saw certain bands or
comics and whatever you're into were you
like oh i want to be them you know what
i mean
i don't when i even when i was in canada
what i saw was younger comics being like
oh you know i want to be
tim dillon or andrew schultz or joe you
know i saw a lot of that
and i i'm doing shows every night and i
i we're selling out and i'm seeing
19 year old kids being like you know
you're my favorite comic that's what i
want to do you know
i don't see a ton of you know young
people right now
or even like you know i don't if you
guys don't know the nilk boys and all
that kind of movement or whatever i see
a lot of kids being like that's what i
want to be
i don't see a lot of kids being like you
know
oh i want to be one of the on snl like i
don't i just don't i just don't see it
the same way right now
unless you were you know specifically
going through groundlings and whatever
obviously
that's the the dream or whatever but so
i think a lot of the
the cool kids in my opinion so to speak
that's who
that's who i care about like who's the
you know kid that is sort of the taste
maker and he's 18. like what does he
think
does he who does he like you know that's
kind of the one that i want
that's who i want to think i'm funny no
absolutely and look
when i started in the open mic it's you
know very ramshackle
there was just a lot of the times just a
mic in the corner of a pub
and you know you went and did your jokes
and sometimes horrendous sometimes it
was awful
but the thing that i loved i loved the
most about it was a sense of freedom to
me
it was the closest thing to punk rock
that i've ever experienced
and do you not sometimes think both of
them are weird
yeah exactly both of them are weird but
do you sometimes think that this
particular movement that we're involved
in
is sort of a punk rock it's a sort of
backlash against
people saying you can't say this you
can't do this and whatever else
yeah it is for sure and the but the
the counter culture of it definitely is
but it goes through phases right and
and you know what how there's that thing
with companies where
it always kind of falls apart a little
bit on the you know second or third
generation of a family or
or whatever i mean when you talk about
punk everyone there
that is part of that movement wasn't
part of making it right
so if you talk about comedy no one here
was the founders
is part of it right so it's kind of the
same reason why
it's easier to tear stuff down than it
is to build it right and there's always
a specific set of circumstances and
energy and things you're pushing back
against
and then eventually everyone sort of
gets in
and no one really knows why those things
are you just know that you fight it you
know what i mean
they go what you know we just know that
we hate this side and you go well why
did they
hate it at then and it doesn't matter if
it flipped
none of this matters i just know this is
what i think so i think that
um there's always
a punk rock element but every industry
has its punk rock faction i mean
silicon valley has its you know kind of
cowboys of silicon valley
who are doing things differently the i'm
sure that if you were in the
the university world has its cowboys who
are sort of not going with the agenda so
um i think that every industry has its
its rebels and freethinkers
and comedy because
hollywood controlled the purse strings
they sort of then started to control the
thought
and then i think that now that's leaving
it's becoming kind of more punk rock
again
do you think that's going to stay as an
internet phenomenon ryan or do you think
it's going to bleed more and more into
the mainstream
as uh my girlfriend always says to me
you know whenever i moan about this
stuff about you know the mainstream not
being interested
she always says the words capitalism
always wins and what does she mean by
that
and she means that eventually you know
the mainstream is going to realize that
the
that the money is in the counter culture
therefore they're going to bring people
from the counter culture
yeah and a lot of them already have but
the problem is
the system's already changing i mean in
the last six years we used to
um you know people used to watch cable
and now you
watch two different two or three
different streaming services and that's
what the thing is right
so it's already changing i mean the
biggest people are youtubers so
the problem is and this is what happened
with rap music back in the day i mean
the labels didn't want anything to do
with it they're ready we're rock
stations we don't touch this right
and then now there's you know seven or
eight rap billionaires and that's why
and i mean
joe rogan everyone for a million years
was like oh
you know we don't this is some beneath
us thing and then yeah
some company wanted to get involved with
it and what they have to do drop off a
bag of money at his house so you know
it's kind of
you have to think of it like silicon
valley seed rounds where yeah
you can go invest in amazon right now
but it's
it's a 100 times more expensive than if
you got in at the beginning
so yeah i think that you know you look
at some of these people i have lots of
friends and i'm doing really well i have
friends that
you know the industry's coming to them
like offering them the same thing and
they're like dude i'm
rich like i don't know what i'm rich and
i'm selling out like
big huge places like you think you're
gonna offer me the i just showed up deal
so yeah they can kind of get involved by
offering huge amounts of money and
they also have less influence and i
think that's you know even with like
louis ck when he got the deal he goes
i'm not going to make changes
you know so the pow they're just
bleeding power
so yeah anyone can buy their way back
into things but it's just going to cost
them a lot and the
the game is going to be shifted by then
you sound quite optimistic ryan g
so i guess if if we follow the
historical trajectory like 20 30 years
ago it was the religious right that was
like you can't say that
now it's sort of the the newly religious
left
do you reckon 10 years from now the
right are going to make a comeback and
they're going to be like
you know what you mustn't blaspheme and
whatever else
it's a tough one because yeah i i think
i
am optimistic partially because it's a
better way to be
i mean you can choose which of those two
you are and neither is
you know uh sure to be right but
i do understand that there's so much you
know there these are real problems just
because it
you know just because you're optimistic
doesn't mean i don't understand
the onslaught that's happening on
citizens in terms of
lying to them and the control and the
power grabs and the the thought
you know control like i do see it all
and i do think it's a problem but i do
think that
probably it would be i think it would be
less of
it goes the other way and my hope would
be more that this leads to further
decentralization and i think that's
probably a good thing
i don't know if we see comedians become
mega stars the way that you know ricky
gervais does again i think that i think
that
the fraction fractionalization maybe is
a positive thing so
i i see that the more decentralized it
becomes probably
the better and maybe people do own their
little corner of the internet and i
don't necessarily see that as a
a negative or a positive it's just uh
reordering
and reorganizing and i think that's
what's happening in a lot of industries
including comedy that there's
sort of a reorganizing of what exactly
this is going to happen i mean we were
talking about the other day
that in you know like nfts and all that
sort of stuff right
you know they're talking about the idea
of and they already have it but the idea
of
attaching like trigonometry would be
attached to an nft where you're
essentially a stock and people can
invest in you
you know as a as a company and i'm sure
you've seen someone come on the comedy
scene before where you go
oh that guy that guy's got something you
know
i'd like to invest in that and then you
could put money into it but you know we
have patreons and everyone has that sort
of thing but
the way that you could bet on you know
the the future of an artist the way you
could on a
on on a company and i think that in
music especially
there's there's no way to make money and
the music industry sort of fell apart
for that i mean
you know when you were a kid i'm sure
you could name 50 bands that you
you know who was the the biggest band to
come out in the next 10 years like
essentially
that is over you know on a lot of it for
all intensive purposes so
i think that some of the there's just so
many
there's so many people that are working
so hard and i meet you know i'm talking
to you guys i meet so many people that
i'm very impressed with you know the way
their brains work and their
understanding of the world and their
understanding for like problem solving
and solutions and trying and i think
there's a lot of people trying right now
so i think that
there's going to be a lot of cool
solutions coming out of it and i already
see some of them and i already see
that's what america's cool for too and i
don't know uk that well but
i have so many friends they're just like
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this i
mean you know like i'm gonna get a
studio what if i ran my own studio i've
all five employees like i'll do this
what if we tour
and every everyone's like move makers
and i think you know i just got a new
studio so i got my house i got my studio
and then
i'm running my little uh uh
you know my podcast business and i'm
running my thing and i'm touring every
week and if we're all kind of running
our own little businesses
and i see a lot of people with ideas
then you kind of look ego maybe i'll do
that
and then you you know so i think that
i'm a little bit
uh positive with i'm impr i'm impressed
with you know people's ability to
persevere a little bit so that that's
the part where i
i still see stuff that people make and i
go oh or talk to people and hear the
ideas they have for the future and i go
oh
cool you know so i think that that
that's why
where i see it reorganizing could be
positive and it's going to come up with
it might come out the other end with
some new ways of doing things and i
think it already has i like
you know instead of five big companies
deciding who's popular everyone can kind
of run their own business i think it's
making
better stuff and i think it's people
have a better place to listen to news
and better place to
find comedy and whatever they want so i
think that might continue to get better
or option two is it's completely
cracked down it becomes and we all
become communist countries and that
that's a wrap on the western world so i
don't know we'll see well
one thing i take away from this is we
desperately need to google nfts mate
yeah exactly i've got no
i'm not i'm not an expert at that i the
only thing that i
really understand about it is why
couldn't what if i
invested in you and then so let's say
you know let's say someone invested in
me when i first moved to new york right
and then now you'd say oh ryan's coin
his stock is worth this much
so even if you didn't like me you could
have bought you know stalking me
and then now it would have you know be
worth whatever amount so you can
invest in someone that you don't even
necessarily because you like them just
because you
believe in their growth so i think that
that's like potential pause
a positive of the future do you have a
website
or do you plan to have a website well if
you do
then easy dns are the company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients
whether it be cancel culture d platform
attacks
or overzealous government agencies he
knows a bit about that
so will you in a second easy dns have
rock-solid
network infrastructure and incredible
customer support
they're in your corner no matter what
the world throws at you
unless it's your ex-girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you'd know about
that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns
right now all you've got to do is head
over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50
off the initial purchase sign up for
their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know
about technology privacy and censorship
and brian we we've seen covid
obviously we've seen all this you know
you know this nonsense happening or you
know online trying to shut people down
whatever else
do you think that there is still an
appetite after covid for live comedy
live performance
or do you think more and more people are
just going to think to themselves why
would i go to a gig
when i can just stay in and watch
netflix or consume my content online
i'm well i'm selling a lot of my shows
right now new york comedy's back and
it's pretty full but
i think one of the things that when
people
uh talk about that question they forget
is like
comey's just a date you know what i mean
so i think a lot of people
especially if you're in you know london
or new york or something you would go
okay we're going to go i'm going to take
out you know me and my girl are going to
go do you want to go to dinner we could
i don't know i guess we could go see a
show or we could go to comedy
it's like i think it's those things sort
of just work their way into
you know especially people that are kind
of 20 to 35 i think it just becomes a
thing
that people do so i there is comedy fans
and they'll always go to comedy
but in terms of normal people i don't
think that if you're super scared you
might be like for another two years i'm
not doing anything i'm one of those and
i'm
you know not gonna leave my garage
without a mask on and even then i have
four masks on
but i think that the the comedy where
it's like i'm just gonna go see a show
because it's a date i think that'll
always happen and
and people that are watching you know
people online and stuff if anything it's
easier for them to get to their shows
because they actually kind of follow
them
remember be like think about like 20
years ago if you had like an
album and it was kind of you know
successful you know and you
had a little following and people and
you go how would they even know that you
have shows
like this is before even mailing lists
like how do they even know they just
have to see a flyer that you're playing
how'd you even communicate whereas you
guys talk to all your fans once a week
and you say hey we're going to be here
so i don't know i think that it's
probably better i have a question for
you guys
do you guys agree okay so a lot of
canadians come to america and they do
pretty well right
it's a that's sort of a known thing that
there's a hot like a very high
percentage of canadians that are
successful in america
and my thoughts is is because canada
is the mix between uk comedy and
american comedy so com american
companies very like almost taking a
small premise or taking
a small punch line and almost making it
bigger like you almost oversell
and british is you sort of try to take
big punch lines and like undersell them
almost throw them away even though
they're big jokes
and i think we're sort of the in between
where we a little more
flashy but we under we're kind of still
the you know
the small with the punchlines and
sarcasm
right could it just be that the [ __ ]
canadians stay in canada
oh 100
but even then the percentage is still
high way higher even it's not
i'm not saying the percentage of
canadians that come here is higher like
yeah obviously
i have that conversation all the time
where people are you know all canadians
are all great and you go oh there's
plenty of bad comedians
they're just not here yeah well you guys
are so great you're like yeah the five
of us that
you know got green cards to immigrate
here so you are right but even then
there's a higher percentage of even uh
the per population it's way higher
i i think it's because canadians are
likeable do you know what i mean
yeah you know there's sometimes like you
see an american comedian and it's very
interesting they come over like i
i introduced this one guy to the stage
i'm not gonna say his name right okay
and i was emceeing a gig
and he was like dude i want you to tell
them all about my hbo
series i want you to tell them about my
special i wanted to tell you
all about this how i crushed this how i
crushed that that's an american accent
by the way
that was the name of the special that he
told you to tell him i can't remember
i'll tell you afterwards right okay
it is and then yeah i'll tell you who it
is afterwards and then i went
are you sure you want me to do this he
was like absolutely he walked out on
so i said everything that he did right
and then as he walked out on stage you
saw the 120 english people go
all right then [ __ ] make a sloth
yeah
and he played to silence for about 20
minutes
and he came off sweating he was like
dude man that was a tough crowd dude you
screwed up my intro
but i just think it's part of that
you've got sort of the american
confidence but as well like there's this
sort of
british or almost european
self-deprecation i see a lot of
canadians doing self-deprecating humor
that i don't think as much americans do
in my experience
yeah americans have a little more ego
probably in general right
even when they're the self-depreciating
uh
you know i'm depressed comedians it's
it's still
you know comes with a ton of ego really
it's still all based around that
but you're right as you said that i
never even said that but there are a lot
of comedians where their jokes are so
funny you're just like
in america you're just like man this
guy's unlikable
[Laughter]
well it's it's a different style isn't
it it's a different style
ryan so what's next for you because you
know you seem hopeful that
all of this stuff is going to gradually
uh move on
uh uh you know yeah am i writing words
in your mouth though yeah yeah
i just don't want to be the guy that's
like oh this isn't a big deal it's
nothing
it's all gonna sort itself out but it it
could
you know it could and i think that you
should probably
operate towards that instead of towards
uh
it's over you know it's i always say
it's you know for example i think it's
just the playing the victim
it's like you can't play the other way
too right it's there's so many people
that are like
let's say they work at a job and there's
some 20 year old dude and they go
they're only promoting other people and
they're against me it's like yes stop
working there
do you know what i mean like you know in
canada i was part of this system and it
was oppressive and whatever it's like
yeah move if you live in new york and
you don't like the way it is like yeah
you can
move to texas and if you're in an
industry that's not
working towards you move and do
something else i mean there's
so i just i'm i'm a proponent of people
there's always an opportunity and
there's always
um a way for you to win even if you
think the thing's getting worse
so i think that it's important to no i
get it no i
agree with you completely that's our
attitude no it makes perfect sense and
it's always been our attitude on
trigonometry like
as i say we've paid a price for doing
the show
but we've got the rewards that come with
that and we're that's cool
but we also do interview a lot of people
people who are you know a guy in his 50s
who
who started a charity for kids in the in
the city he made a criticism of blm
and then goku kicked out of his own
charity yeah that guy
isn't going to move to texas do you know
what i mean like
i mean you know he obviously is doing a
press tour about it you know he's on
your
i mean you could that that literally
describes what happened to jordan
peterson who's now the biggest
you know cultural figure of our
generation or brett weinstein or any of
those guys you know what i mean
what you described is legitimately
essential like kind of what happened to
them
and i mean again it doesn't always work
out but i mean
for when we talk about you know there's
someone okay so if we talk about right
now that there's someone that
there's someone that invested in dodge
coin or someone that put all their money
in some stock and now they're
you know worth 100 million dollars and
there's also a guy
that put all his money into his stock
and his family's bankrupt and he's
living in a van right now and he doesn't
have custody of his kids and
so it's just the idea i think it kind of
comes
you know when you guys are talking about
like there's a system and
you you know then you work at this club
and then you feature and then you work
your way up to headliner and then you
get
a writing job here and eventually you
know that's the system for that and it's
like
yeah this is uncharted territory and it
is like the wild west
a lot of ways and sometimes in the wild
west you get shot and
of course i'm against that like i'm not
like yeah whatever he got shot that
sucks i'm like yeah this
is crazy but you are right like if
if you that's why i say to people a lot
of times people go to me
like comics and they're like i want to
say this stuff you know i want to do the
stuff you're doing but i don't have
i'm afraid of the thing and i go most of
the time i
if i know these people maybe i don't say
this but a lot of times i know them i go
yeah you know you're right you're not
cut out for this like you know what i
mean
so be honest with yourself like if
you're the type of guy that you're 60
and you aren't cut out for you know
sort of fighting then yeah don't tweet
online your opinions about blm like
honestly it's so
it is yeah these are like risks and
it doesn't make it right it doesn't make
it right that someone's you know
like uh out in the you know out at a
saloon and they just get shot because
they bumped into the wrong guy
but you've got to be honest about what
the the situation is in the world right
now and
what what risk reward you want to put
yourself into
well that's what i was going to ask you
about because let's be honest
all three of our careers to some extent
actually benefit from this craziness
being in existence right yeah but maybe
you would have been super successful
before too right yeah
i definitely would have been but yeah
honestly you know i like how
i've been successful like two other
times doing other things like you know
the
the a lot of times the um like
the whatever factor that both of them
have is you you know what i mean so
you is it that you benefited from it but
it's also
you flourished in whatever the
environment was is probably you know
better way
you know more positive way to put it
about you but i guess what i'm getting
at is
would you prefer to be talking about
other stuff than
than this or are you happy to just
satirize or mock whatever is happening
in society you're not really that
attached i think that
when it started i did feel a little
um the way that you're talking about
in that you almost i think my friend put
it in an interesting way there's like a
culture war that you got drafted to
do you know what i mean because they
basically say here's the things you have
to think and you have to say them and i
go
no i'm not going to say that and they go
well then you're on the other team and
so there was a bit of that
but i think that it's not so much
that the stuff in a lot of ways is
irrelevant to me
i'm going to talk about where the energy
is
so let's say that you know 9 11 happened
right
and you you you could say you know well
i don't want to talk about that but if
it's the number one issue in america
right now
that that that isn't a choice you're
making you know what i mean
so you can you can i think that it's
it's almost like arrogant to pretend
that
what's important to me is independent of
this like i'm really into this thing and
that's what it is
it's like you know there's the culture
and there's an energy and
so you're in some ways reaction to that
and if you're a comedian
you want to be you know uh
talking about where the world's where
you disagree you go
what's something that i really think
that i feel like everyone's wrong about
and maybe what that is is irrelevant and
i think one of the in some of it's both
right like i always was really into the
differences between men and women as
much as that's like
you would say that it's all you know the
hack version of women are from mars
controversial now ryan well that but
that's what i mean so that was something
i was always
re like you know me and my friends
talking for hours about this is why
girls do that you know
just that's something that's always been
very very interesting me like
psychologically
and i maybe didn't even notice that that
me and my friends just have always
trying to get to the bottom of something
you know what i mean
about why girls are the way so that like
you said so that kind of became like a
taboo thing
that i happen to already be interested
in talking about i think
i i whenever it became the trump thing
a lot of times i made a few things about
trump but generally on stage i wouldn't
talk about him
i would always kind of talk about the
issues without his presence in my actual
bits like i don't
really say his name so you can so i
tried to get creative with
um inserting the things i want to talk
about into the cultural conversation and
vice versa
now and ryan the thing is i you know we
are
we're all charting our path we're all
you know making our own way
it's great but there's one thing that
we're all
at the behest of and we are incredibly
vulnerable to
yes exactly finally someone talking
about what francis wants to talk yeah
exactly uh no it's uh it's it's
basically
being cancelled having you know being d
platform from twitter
youtube and the rest of it i deal with
that on a daily basis yeah it sucks no i
it really does suck
um and it's it's
it's a bad situation for in terms of
that i mean
i've gotten like a youtube strike and
i'm trying you know i try to put myself
into a position where i
you know try to have a guy there try to
look at what the things are and i try to
push those lines i mean
so i go back and forth on that because
for one
there is this idea that on one side you
go oh you should be able to say anything
comedy was never about saying anything i
mean you go stand in front of an
audience who has a certain
level of things they're gonna all have a
point where they're that's too much for
them find where that point is
and really get freaking close to it and
then
bring them back and you know that to me
that's kind of when comedy is at its
best or what i like at least right
so when you're on the even with
structuring when i
when i write a script like we're working
on a movie one of the things that a lot
of people
do is they kind of one of your things
needs to be grounded right so
um if you go let me just make like the
wacky crazy show
then if you're plotting stuff wacky
crazy like then your character should be
grounded or
something should be grounded if
everything just it's just uncomfortable
so there's
there's never no boundaries so i guess
these platforms are another place where
there's boundaries but the problem is
not so much that there's boundaries the
bound the problem for me
is that the boundaries are clearly
um lopsided and they change based on
like they're they're like hypocritical
and they're lying you know what i mean
where they're well they're saying oh you
can't do this but what they really mean
is
we're just gonna censor are some
political candidates we like and which
ones we don't like so i think
i think that that is a real conversation
that a lot of people are having right
now and it's probably good that it's at
the forefront and a lot of people have
i don't know exactly what it's like in
uk i know canada is different but in
america
i probably think that facebook
twitter instagram youtube these places
essentially have a monopoly on speech
and they've become to some degree
utilities so there is a point where i
would probably think that they should be
operating in accordance with the first
amendment and i don't know there's
it's a tough one because you see all
these companies and they love the
censorship because they just kind of use
it for regulatory capture like mark
zuckerberg's like
if anything you should make us have more
people that fact check you know and
so essentially ostensibly no one could
ever create a social media site ever
again
there's a lot of people with different
um
competing interests and comedy and
speech is sort of almost a casualty to
some degree in this you know
politicians want to lobby the liberal
politicians want to lobby the companies
to
you know they say they're not censoring
enough the conservatives say they're
censoring too much because they're
getting censored more
and then you know a lot of these
companies probably just don't want to be
in the speech game at all but they're
getting
everyone's yelling at them like you're
letting this on your platform but you're
already allowed to block people on the
platform you're already there already is
if you are harassing someone
you know there already is harassment
laws that i think you're not immune to
because you're on
twitter and facebook so i i think that
at the end of this conversation
that the world's having right now if it
got a little closer to that i think that
would be positive
i think that if it became a situation
where there's
if it became uh less
if it became more centralized i think
that would probably be negative so
um i i'm not sure where that's gonna go
what do you guys think
no well we've we've been talking about
this a hell of a lot man and it's
interesting and it's tough yeah yeah
it's an unsolvable puzzle in many ways
but
listen we'll say that for next time we
have you back on the show uh we're going
to do a couple of questions for locals
in the seg but before we do
uh our last question is always the same
francis is desperate to ask i'm off
desperate what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
the one thing that we're not talking
about oh is
i would say one thing that i've done a
decent amount of videos about lately
is i think that there is way too many
people
essentially getting life advice from
depressed people
and i think that we need a little bit of
a resurgence of the six
the six years ago kind of tech mentality
of um you know that it's important
to get advice from people
who are successful and so you know what
i mean
there's a lot of people that are
depressed their life's a mess
but they have the answers for you
they're telling you what to do
so i think we should talk we should
put pride on on being successful having
your life together
you know being in a state of mental
health being you know
uh living your life in an optimistic way
rather than
that be sort of uh like all this guy
he's got it all figured out
i think that there's there's a there's
like an odd
um people people look highly
on people that their life's a mess like
there's some virtue
in being a mess and uh being
you know unemployable and depressed and
fighting with your girlfriend and
and all that sort of stuff so i think
that i i think that
i like people that are unapologetically
great
and i think that's i i think there might
be a resurgence of that and i see it
with dudes a lot of dudes kind of
looking at guys like that again i think
that that that's probably a good way to
put i think
we're not talking about enough about the
greatness of dudes that are
unapologetically great yeah
make america great again
no i don't yeah not in america i just
think that guys like
people yeah you're generally trying to
put me put that
on what you're saying is don't take life
advice from comedians we hear you loud
and clear
yeah yeah comedians is a funny one yeah
you comedian you go
you got this guy you know he's 45 with
you know five roommates and he's telling
you
what you should be spending your time
doing like you guys should be doing this
and this and this you go
you should literally be looking at him
and doing the opposite that's what you
should be doing
that's exactly right listen ryan thank
you very much where can people if
they're not already familiar with your
work which most of them will be where
can people find you online
the boys cast with ryan long comes out
every
friday and uh patreon.com the boys cast
an episode comes an extra episode comes
out every week
and then every monday and that that's on
youtube um
and on my youtube.com ryan long comedy
and all my socials are at ryan long
comedy and
every monday i release a
sketch comedy comedy skit
well they are all fantastic i really
recommend anyone who's not familiar with
them go check them out
ryan thanks for coming on and thank you
for watching at home we will see you
with another brilliant episode
or a raw show all of them go out at 7pm
uk time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below